aujourd'hui on voit des films qui
coûtent 100 200 millions de dollars sur
les kiffe qui sortent plus en plateforme
mais en ces plateformes sont aussi en
train de changer on a remarqué j'ai fait
un voyage récemment à Los Angeles pour
essayer de comprendre un petit peu
comment le marché américain fonctionnait
aujourd'hui on remarque d'une part dans
un marché qui n'est pas du tout régulé
où il n'y a aucune aide ou l'état
n'intervient pas
on ne voit que des films à 150 millions
de dollars ou plus les seuls projets de
cinéma qu'on voit là-bas ce sont ceux-là
ou des films des petits documentaires
des petits films à moins de 5 millions
de nous payer en France un cinéma
extrêmement envié c'est la diversité des
films qu'on a et cette diversité là elle
nous permet aussi à nous de faire des
gros films elle nous permet aussi on a
on a fait Astérix on a aussi fait revoir
Paris dans nos cours le prochain film de
Xavier Beauvois les films de Var le
cinéma c'est cette diversité là et c'est
cette diversité qui permet à la fois de
renouveler les talents de renouveler la
création et nous permettre aussi de
faire ces films spectaculaires et ces
films grand public qui permettent aux
gens de venir en salle de cinéma